meanwhile let's talk a little bit about
something that is going on in eatonville
uh washington this high school there in
eatonville they've got this program
if you are on a sports team regardless
of the team you've got to wear this
ankle tracker it's kind of like an ankle
bracelet sure absolutely
an ankle bracelet or a prisoner same
thing anyway what they're doing is
they're trying to figure out
the school in their wisdom said okay
we're trying to keep the kids socially
distanced so we're going to
get a contract with this company for
these ankle trackers
it's got visual and audible sensors when
kids are too close to each other so if
i'm within whatever they set it for six
feet of another kid with another ankle
monitor it goes off the whole idea is to
keep the kids apart but then the parents
found out about it hey wait a minute
impossible the school is tracking the
children the school said look
they leave it at school we're not
tracking your kids but one mother said
ankle bracelets are for criminals not
for kids right and so they're having a
school board meeting tonight because now
they're saying all right we won't make
you do this until we hear the
community's input this is uh from the
school's superintendent gary neil he
says we received grant funding that
specifically included provisions to
support higher risk athletic programs
and we use some of those funds to pay
for athletic proximity monitors we are
using these monitors for high contact
and moderate indoor contact sports the
monitors are for both staff coaches and
students on the field regardless if they
are vaccinated or unvaccinated if a
student or coach tests positive we will
have immediate information regarding
athletes and coaches and contacts so we
can more tightly determine who might
need to quarantine right and of course
if you get too close to somebody that
really makes sense so if you're playing
soccer or football you get too close to
an unboxing in person it goes off
evidently it's not so much in the
laboratory stage it's already happened a
15 year old girl allegedly forced to
wear an ankle tracking monitor for
volleyball practice in eatonville in a
condition of participating in the sport
it was required to both vaccinated and
unvaccinated
just find a way to let them play keeping
the rules i mean the mass were a joke
last year the role in every kid's chin
and plus we found out about outdoor
activities it's almost impossible to get
it it didn't stop the oregon governor
for coming out and saying you now have
to wear a mask outdoors so
and
both vaccinated and unvaccinated
athletes have to wear it but this was
the
deal the administration made
to allow unvaccinated kids to actually
play the sport so you know everybody's
gotta wear it because they can't figure
it out okay who's unvaccinated right the
intentions might be good but the parents
are outraged about this and down in palm
beach you saw that remember governor
desantis says no mask mandates for our
statement down in palm beach county
we're going to talk to some parents
they're furious because palm beach
county the school district there has
said now the kids no matter if they're
vaccinated or not they cannot opt out of
this masked mandate they have to wear
masks all right we will keep you posted
we got an appearance panel coming up in
the seven o'clock hour on that